[Música]
plata o plomo puede parecer exagerado
pero para mí es la frase idónea para
definir cuál es cuál es la situación
actual del periodismo en méxico y en
chihuahua sólo el año pasado asesinaron
a 12 de mis colegas uno por mes uno por
mes y hasta este momento todos siguen en
completa impunidad mucha gente me
pregunta por qué a diario platico con
personas es una de mis principales
funciones de mi trabajo y me preguntan
por qué los periodistas siempre hablamos
de muerte de dinero o de poder porque
este campo semántico es la catarsis de
nuestra profesión es el núcleo de
nuestro ámbito y de nuestro oficio lo
más deprimente para un periodista es que
lo callen y que lo silencien lo más
deprimente y lo más perverso es que
alguien con poder se coaccione y te diga
que puedes decir que puedes hacer
no puedes decir una de las cosas que a
mí me motivaron para hablar fue una mi
madurez y dos un cierto grado de
rebeldía y de locura que siempre he
tenido desde niño una de las cosas que
más me preocupaba a mí era saber qué
tanto iba a afectar a mi familia con lo
que yo pudiera publicar una de las
experiencias más fuertes y cómo fue
donde yo ya comenté comencé a
experimentar lo que es que te priven de
tu libertad de expresión es cuando
decidí dejar mi casa a los 19 años para
venirme a vivir a la ciudad de chihuahua
y tratar de ser alguien en los medios de
comunicación para mí una persona que
tiene un teléfono no es mi enemigo pero
sí representa una competencia y sobre
todo representa alguien que me puede
dejar sin chamba ustedes todos ustedes
todos los que están sentados aquí pueden
tomarse un choque un homicidio y con
toda tranquilidad pueden sacar su
celular y comenzar a grabar poner en
modo self y
y reportar qué es lo que está sucediendo
no critico este ámbito del periodismo
porque yo me dedico a otra cosa así como
ustedes tienen esa cualidad de poder
sacar su teléfono muchos no tienen no
quiero decir que no tengan la capacidad
pero no tienen la paciencia y el esmero
de durar meses y meses correteando a un
funcionario correteando una
investigación y siendo muy disciplinado
en los métodos porque decir que tú eres
mentiroso es irresponsable porque
acusarte a ti de que cometiste un acto
de corrupción puede ser hasta un delito
un verdadero un verdadero periodista
indaga pregunta antes de publicar algo
antes de atreverse a abrir la boca
necesita asegurarse con fuentes
fidedignas que realmente es cierto lo
que va a decir mi carrera inició en
tvazteca aquí en chihuahua una de las
empresas que más me enseñó de lo bueno y
de lo malo una empresa que estaba
sometida al poder como muchos
periodistas lo estuvieron
en uno de los extremos más
altivos y corruptos que hemos vivido en
nuestra actualidad como fue el pasado
aquí en el estado de chihuahua necesito
un ejemplo muy sencillo había
periodistas que además de sus ingresos
básicos que era alrededor de 12 mil
pesos porque además de que no se exponen
los pagan muy mal mucha gente piensa que
porque salgo en la tele gano super bien
y me va a como carlos loret de mola
eliminen esa idea de su cabeza es todo
lo contrario pero bueno
cuando hacemos un paréntesis en esta
inclusión en la empresa me empiezo a dar
cuenta que hay intereses mucho más
grandes que yo y mucho más grandes que
la gente que nos veía atrás de esa
empresa estaba un hombre que aspiraba a
ser presidente de la república
imagínense un chavo de 19 años con su
acento norteño te y bien inmaduro en la
capital del estado sacando a relucir los
actos de corrupción de uno de los
hombres más poderosos no del estado del
país porque si las cosas no se hubieran
publicado porque si gente no hubiera
levantado la voz posiblemente él ahorita
estaría conteniendo para ser presidente
de la república y no exagero
esas eran sus metas como inició mi
trabajo de investigación en azteca no lo
pude desarrollar mucho porque tenía
jóvenes que estaban sometidos y que eran
mis amigos pero también mis enemigos
porque antes de publicar se asustaban o
porque me mandaban a entrevistar
gobernadores a jefes del gobierno y
créanme que casi cuando yo llegaba a la
redacción estaban con un rosario en la
mano no los culpo de eso viven si les
adjudicó cierta responsabilidad en la
descomposición en social que estamos
viviendo pero es parte del trabajo que
ellos han desarrollado cuando yo empecé
a señalar actos de corrupción lo que
pasó fue lo siguiente
no dude ni siquiera dos años porque me
habían despedido era tanta la presión de
los convenios de publicidad que el
gobierno le pasaba en la empresa no
estamos hablando de 100 mil pesos
estamos hablando de casi 30 millones de
pesos anuales imagínense tener en su
cartera 30 millones de pesos por
callarse eso es lo que cuesta la voz de
un periodista en chihuahua y había
ejemplos más drásticos como les
comentaba había colegas que además de
recibir su sueldo de 12 15 mil pesos
mensuales recibían 50 mil pesos del
gobierno nada más por guardar silencio
obviamente cuando ven a alguien que
empieza a levantar la voz hay
ofrecimientos pero ya es cuestión de
cada uno decidir ser amigo de los que
gobiernan ser amigos de los que ostentan
el poder o decidir tener un granito de
dignidad y trabajar para quien estás
obligado a rendirle cuentas que es la
gente porque al final de cuentas cuando
tú estás en la televisión
podrás tener productores atrás que te
están friegue y friegue desde cómo te
ves cómo te peinas como hablas hasta tu
director de noticias que es quien decide
que sí y que no son retos que tienes que
ir burlando constantemente eso no lo
soportaron en la empresa donde yo
trabajaba no soportaron que un joven
tuviera no me quiero no quiero hacer
esto entonces y decir que era yo el más
valiente pero al menos me atrevía y al
menos decidí salir a salir de esa área
de confort porque estaba ante un reto
personal muy grave decía
si hablo se me va a quitar la comodidad
mi sueldo mis contactos pero si no hablo
pasó a este hemisferio de mentira
perversidad y ya hasta delincuente
porque no hay mayor acto de corrupción
que saber algo y callarte eso es más
grave muchas veces que cometer lo luego
de esta vorágine de sentimientos cuando
me despidieron estaba en la tarde en mi
departamento y decidí publicar porque me
habían despedido y cuál fue la respuesta
que me dieron mis jefes salió
solicitarles una explicación clara de
por qué me estaban dejando en la calle
sin un peso y totalmente solo en una
ciudad donde apenas si tenía un año y
medio donde no tenía verdaderos amigos
porque eso lo vas descubriendo con el
tiempo y de dónde te encuentras en una
zona donde la soledad o se convierte en
tu enemigo o se convierte en tu mejor
amigo para explotar tus verdaderas
capacidades fue ahí donde en ese día
decidí dedicarme al periodismo de
investigación
van a decir bueno pues este es jorge
ramos o que se creo que es lo que pasa
no pero en chihuahua hacía falta nada
más
hablar con la verdad para sobresalir
llegue a discusiones tan banales y tan
absurdas con mis jefes de información
que me exigían decirle al gobernador
señor gobernador porque si yo no le
decía señor gobernador me descontaban de
mi sueldo puede parecer ridículo incluso
a mí me daba un montón de coraje que me
hicieran llamarle así pero bueno tienes
que ceder me veían ahí en mis
entrevistas señor gobernador porque se
robó tantos millones es así bien bien
amable
hay gente
en el mismo trabajo que des me criticaba
ególatra como eres protagonista como
muere sangrón y otros adjetivos aún más
graves pero no me importaba tienes que
llegar en un punto donde la
determinación es tu mejor aliado después
de esto entré a trabajar a un canal y
aquí es donde quiero hacer un
señalamiento de que es investigación y
que es una simple nota donde pasaba
meses sin publicar un solo reportaje
porque no tenía fuentes confiables la
vez que publiqué mi primer reportaje fue
de la inseguridad de chihuahua y una de
las entrevistas más álgidas que he
tenido en mi vida la van a ver a
continuación
no hace falta que lo presente
listo está la ciudad de méxico con más
de 10 puntos en el estado de chihuahua
no es incongruente que usted vaya a
hablar al senado sobre seguridad y esté
pasando esto en su ciudad de ninguna
manera porque chihuahua tiene claros
avances de seguridad solo el que no lo
quiere ver no lo ve tintas
usted se destruye su carrera política
con lo que pasó ayer en el senado cae en
los precios del petróleo en un a nivel
internacional ponen en riesgo los
proyectos energéticos antiguos
que vamos a hablar como hombres si
quiere una entrevista vamos a una
entrevista le preocupa sus obligaciones
económicas y distribuyen estás preguntas
y atribuirse esas personas es una falta
de respeto y un motivo como soy un
trabajo en mí es una parte de respeto a
su actitud yo estoy a tus órdenes y le
estoy contestando lo que me prestes ok
vamos a ver vamos a chambear porque para
eso nos pagan se destruye su carrera
política con lo que pasó ayer en el
senado porque se va a destruir me
preguntó no de ninguna manera el
contrario soy gobernador de chihuahua y
es una mentira lo que javier corral ahí
planteaba
de que yo estoy en un proceso judicial
no es cierto si estoy en un proceso
judicial no sería gobernador del estado
no puede estar en funciones es un
mentiroso el senador corral
ahora es prófugo de la justicia los
gobernados
bueno
después de investigaciones muy arduas
descubrimos y publicamos los contratos
de publicidad que los dan le daban a los
medios de comunicación les comento es de
30 millones hasta el diario que recibía
90 millones de pesos más presupuesto del
que tienen varios municipios en la
sierra más presupuesto de áreas tan
delicadas como el control de adicciones
así a ese grado llegaron después de
hacer varias publicaciones me topo con
un reportaje que ustedes seguramente lo
conocieron no llegaron a escuchar qué es
la problemática en ávalos desde hace dos
años notificaron al gobierno del estado
de aquel entonces que había niños que
tenían hasta 45 microgramos por
decilitro de sangre de plomo arsénico y
cadmio en su sangre la primera impresión
que me llevé de esos niños es que cuando
los estaba entrevistando les salía
sangre de la nariz y nadie decía nada su
mamá solo ay mi hijo esto pasa muy
normal ellos ya lo veían como un acto
ordinario cuando lo publicamos
se desata la locura en el gobierno
estatal de aquel entonces
y salimos publicados en the guardian the
washington post y en varios medios
internacionales por una acto de es
tremenda y extraordinaria suerte que nos
topamos en internet con una solicitud de
información que hizo el director mi jefe
actual nos topamos con esa información
lo publicamos y es cuando comenzamos a
recibir también varias invitaciones a
que amablemente guardamos en el cajón
esa información y a cambio la cartera se
va a ver beneficiada no aceptamos y ya
por fortuna esos niños están siendo
atendidos la mayoría de ellos ya no
viven ahí y ahorita ya hay un proyecto
de renovación en ávalos después de esto
me hago activista social porque llegué a
un punto donde yo mismo decía tengo
mucha información pero no hago nada nada
más que pararme frente a una cámara a
hablar y publicar dentro del activismo
social y uno de los vídeos donde
casualmente me topé a un candidato y muy
amigo de la persona que acabamos de ver
me lo topo goleando en los zapatos
y ocurrió lo siguiente
[Música]
sigue siendo lo mismo lesionó este
estado aprobando la deuda
también están dañadas en la tracción
que hacer es muchas veces no porque él
te digo la verdad lo único que es lo
único que si usted lo sabe por eso me
ven vaya vaya se llama
lo que más necesita gente
porque tengo la vocación
porque les digo la verdad
a partir de esa tarde frente a palacio
de gobierno deje de llamarme gabriel
ahora soy el mozalbete
mi mamá abro muchísimo planeando mi
nombre y ya mis amigos me dice el
mozalbete hasta allí todo bien
qué valiente muchacho aunque increíble
pero a los dos días tómala me meten a la
cárcel
y va saliendo de una tienda
departamental veo a dos hombres armados
y dije ya valió ahí nos vemos de esta
vida me detuvieron me llevan a la
fiscalía y directamente me llevan al
cereso y no entré con los separos donde
comúnmente llevan a los recién detenidos
me metieron con toda la comunidad
carcelaria carcelaria tuve la dichosa y
extraordinaria oportunidad de dormir con
cinco desconocidos en un cuartito de
tres por tres donde la taza del baño
estaba a 40 centímetros de mí y no les
voy a contar lo demás porque es muy
temprano fue una de las experiencias más
horribles que he tenido en mi vida
cuando un delincuente que cometió un
delito implícitamente sabe que uno de
sus riesgos es parar en la cárcel cuando
una persona trata de llegar trata de
trata de hacer las cosas bien y luchar
por su sociedad jamás se imagina que va
a terminar en la cárcel lidiando con
secuestradores con violadores que se
quieren pasar de vivos es cierto y que
te ofenden que te escupen y que te dicen
miles de cosas que siempre se te van a
quedar grabadas en la mente
créanme que la experiencia más grande
que me quedó de todo esto que sucedió a
lo largo de mi vida y hace unos años es
que no hay peor cárcel y no hay peor
celda que quedarse callado
porque puede soportar
estar en el cerezo puedes tolerar los
insultos los agravios la falta de
confianza y que también se burlen de tu
familia por lo que estás haciendo
pero lo más lo más deprimente de un ser
humano es quedarse callado ante un acto
de injusticia es quedarse callado cuando
tú estás viendo un acto de corrupción
porque no se están robando tu
oportunidad porque no se están robando
solo tu dinero te están robando tus
oportunidades tus sueños
y tu capacidad para alcanzar lo que
tanto anhelas y has anhelado desde niños
porque quedarse callado es robarle vida
a los hijos que tenemos o que algún día
vamos a tener muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]